they are consistently the most likely to
unfriend block and insult people who
hold different beliefs to their own
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator in London today I'm joined by
Matt Goodwin professor of politics at
the University of Kent and author of
four books including Sunny Times
bestseller National populism and his
most recent book values voice and virtue
the new British politics which I
finished this weekend and explores the
change in politics from the onset of
hyper globalization with Margaret
Thatcher through to the populist votes
of the 20 tens and he spoke recently at
the national conservative conference
around the corner the Emanuel I'm sorry
for ruining your weekend
well Matt thank you for coming to speak
with me I'd like to speak about your
books and
um the national conservative conference
which as we speak now is kind of I think
we're maybe on the tail end of a big
Twitter uh flare up with some of
particularly it seems to aggravated the
people that you describe as the
cosmopolitans in your recent book and
and I'm curious also to speak to you
about the conservative party Legacy and
future the labor party where they are
and various things like immigration that
tie in all of these things but I thought
perhaps before going into that
for people who haven't yet read the book
if you might just lay out the the auth
sort of uh theory about traditionalists
and cosmopolitans
and how those movements sort of underlie
British politics yeah sure and I think
in in a sense the con the conference
also speaks to that question and why the
confidence happened
um I I wrote this book because I wanted
to explain why Britain has been upended
over the last decade by what I see is
three interconnected but quite distinct
rebellions you had the rise of of
populism National populism with Nigel
farage which obviously outflanked a lot
of people they didn't see it coming you
then had the vote for brexit again
outflanked much of the establishment and
then you had that post-brexit
realignment with Boris Johnson and the
conservatives in 2019 right that seem to
usher in this new brand of conservative
politics and what I wanted to do in the
book is really say well how on Earth
have we got here why on Earth did all of
that happen and why so many people
frustrated and disillusioned with the
state of the country and and one of the
things that I've personally felt very
frustrated about was how we've been
given many
unconvincing narratives about why all of
that happened we've been told it's
social media we've been told it's Russia
it's you know individual donors it's
campaigners it's what was written on the
side of a Big Red Bus and in the book
really what I say is actually if you
take a step back and look at Britain in
fact if you look at most western
democracies what I would argue is these
rebellions really reflect you know an
understandable response to the rise of a
new Elite within our societies who are
no longer reflecting the values that are
held by millions of people who are no
longer giving those people a sufficient
voice in the institutions and who are
now embracing a very divisive ideology
of radical progressivism which views
some groups as having virtue as having
status as having a sense of moral
righteousness but other groups as
actually being seen as as inferior as
being seen as backward as being seen as
problematic in some way or other and I
think one of the key points about
Britain today is that the the New Elites
are united unlike the old Elite by a set
of liberal Cosmopolitan views and by
that I mean they're much more
aggressively pro-immigration they're
much more supportive of returning
Britain to the European Union they're
much more Universalist in how they think
about identity so they're not really
interested in Britain's distinctive
identity history and culture which
millions of people really do cherish
they want to keep Britain distinct the
new Elite is really much more interested
in reshaping our national identity
around International themes like
diversity or multiculturalism and as as
I said at the conference you know
there's nothing wrong in saying that
Britain is welcoming and diverse but
diversity cannot be the basis of our
national identity because it's like
saying we don't have an identity of our
own and many people out there clearly
feel that we do have an identity that's
worth preserving so my message
essentially is that unless we can
somehow close these gaps unless we can
somehow get people to develop shared
values or at least respect
the fact that people hold different
values and they're just as legitimate
and just as acceptable as those that are
in the corridors of power and unless we
can give people more of a voice in the
National conversation in the media in
the creative Industries and the cultural
institutions in the universities in the
schools
um we're going to have bigger problems
ahead basically is my conclusion that
what we've seen in the 2010s I think
it's tempting to say well that's all
over now we're back to normal the adults
are back in charge I have a different
view actually I think in a in a way we
we could yet come to look at the 2010s
as the beginning of a much more volatile
period in British politics where people
are trying to push back and trying to
reassert who they are and what they
believe in well what what sort of
immediately jumped out to me is is the
idea that the um that things are going
in a certain direction even or have come
in a linear direction as you've
described it even if they may go in a
very different direction as you suggest
there
what I couldn't quite add up was that I
think that the British voters are
actually far more capricious and
um if we of course labor under corbyn
did very bad in 2019 but not so badly in
2017 which I don't think you address in
the book
and now it looks like almost certainly
the next government will be kistama's
labor labor party and so it seems to me
that
the idea that voters or the
traditionalists that you describe are
out of touch of the cosmopolitans who
are who are uh have taken over the labor
party
doesn't quite add up because I think
that the traditionists will end up
voting for those cosmopolitants running
the labor party at the next election
well some of them will but I think if
you look at
where many people in Britain are today I
think going going back to 2019 briefly
is is useful
um
all political realignments are about
demand and Supply so voters are
demanding
a certain response to some issues and
parties are supplying that Demand with a
credible message and leader and that's
basically what Boris Johnson did it's
what Johnson and farage did in a
referendum
partly um it's also what what Blair did
in in the late 90s and the early 2000s
what's happened since 2019 however
is that the conservative party is no
longer supplying that Demand with a
message that is capable of mobilizing
many of those traditionalist voters so
what we've seen
um is many of those voters abandoning
politics altogether
so give you some some evidence for that
when Johnson came in this is a
remarkable statistic but the
conservatives had 76 of all brexit
voters all 76 three-quarters were voting
conservative
when Liz truss left office
that was down to about 35
so the the realignment that was around
brexit was never just about brexit it
was about traditionalism it was about
let's leave the EU let's lower migration
let's put Britain first let's prioritize
National the national Community British
workers
um that realignment had completely been
blown apart now some of those voters
have gone to labor
um you know partly because kirstan has
done quite a good job at sort of moving
back to the center he's actually talked
about accepting brexit he's talked about
um prioritizing British jobs he's done
some an interesting announcement
recently on housing and saying actually
is it right that we have so many
investors from outside of Britain
exploiting and contributing to our
housing crisis so there's been a bit of
a movement on the supply side for labor
but the bigger issue in British politics
today is we no longer have a political
movement that is pitching loudly and
credibly to the millions of Voters who
are basically saying I want cultural
security or cultural freedom from work
progressivism Mass immigration hyper
globalization but I also want Economic
Security right I want this economy to be
reshaped I don't want it to just be
dependent on London and financial
services I want it to be serving The
Wider community and I think that what
you saw both at the natcon conference
and what you saw through the realignment
is really an expression of that desire
for something different for something
much more in tune with where voters are
and just on 2017 because it is a really
interesting point you know Jeremy corbyn
was actually whatever your personal view
of corbyn he was quite interesting for a
number of reasons one is he too
reflected the utter disillusionment with
the established parties and we forget
this corbyn was a populist I mean I
would view Corbin as a left populace he
was a populist he he was some somebody
knew he was authentic you might disagree
with his beliefs but he was authentic
and on the economy on the on on the
economic Axis or politics he was
actually where a lot of Voters were you
know he was saying as we've seen over
the last couple of weeks with the water
companies he was saying look don't trust
these companies to serve the national
interest we should nationalize them you
can't trust these large companies to
deliver on the national interest and you
can't trust Banks and financial services
to always reform capitalism now I don't
agree with his answers but in Ray
raising those questions he resonated
actually with many of the same voters
I'm talking about voters who have to be
blunt have been left behind by the
economic transformation of the country
and are now looking at all of these
cultural things that are happening and
they're saying you know it's I'm not
even in this conversation anymore you
know the people in Westminster are just
kind of imposing this project top down
and that's so all realignments are about
demand and Supply we've got lots of
demand out there but not much Supply
you mentioned the cultural stuff and and
this is something I want to get my head
around but do you really think that the
cult let's say the the radical
Progressive cultural push
it really matters to voters as much as
the housing crisis various economic
problems cost of living inflation do
people give a damn about the trans issue
for example actually when it comes to
the voting it's like actually at the
moment I can't really afford to live so
the first thing I would say is it's not
either or right voters will typically
think about a cluster of issues if you
ask 2019 conservatives today what are
your top issues you're absolutely right
cost of living is number one immigration
is number two National Health Service is
number three okay so
um voters tend to think about a cluster
of issues the second thing to say though
is
never fall into the Trap of thinking
that because of issues are low salience
because they are down the list of
priorities for voters that they don't
care about them and I'll give you one
example
think about the sexualization of
children and the politicization of
children in our schools and the creeping
influence of
radical progressivism
people say to me routinely voters don't
care about that
well
look at America and look at Scotland in
America that issue went from being a
non-issue fringe marginal nobody was
talking about it to becoming a top three
national issue in about three years
it was galvanized by campaigns in
Virginia California and the salience of
that issue rocketed and when it rocketed
people began to take notice of it
Europe brexit I remember journalists
lining up in the early 2010s and said
Matt why not use talking about EU
membership all the time or immigration
you know these are EU membership is a
low salience issue but when people
started talking about it and debating it
it became one of the most important
issues in the country and the last one
was Scotland I remember everyone said no
one cares about culture wars you know
what happened when Nicholas sturgeon
said let's let 16 year olds legally
change their gender
voters started thinking hang on what are
people talking about they started
looking at the question I polled them
only 20 of people said I think this is a
good idea eighty percent looked at it
and said this is nuts this is insane we
should not be allowing children to
change their gender even if you think
people can change their gender without
any medical supervision and any support
and so salience changes and how do you
change salience you have political
entrepreneurs you have people leaders
who are brave enough courageous enough
to turn things that I think many people
care about into highly Salient political
issues I personally don't think that is
divisive culture War politics my view
would be women's rights the rights of
children free speech
opposing political correctness how we
think about our history how we think
about our national identity these are
the foundations of civilization they are
not culture War questions they are
essential questions and the fact that we
talk about them as though they're
cultural questions shows how much
territory conservatives have
seeded over the last 20 years
I probably would agree with you on a lot
of those things but I can't help but
think
that the labor party which hasn't been
strong on a lot of those issues in fact
are pretty weak on them
are still ahead in the polls despite
them and and again forgive me for
hammering the point but they're still
they're still ahead so you know despite
starmer not being able to say 100 of
women don't have penises or whatever it
was that you can say uh they're still I
mean I don't know if it's come down
slightly but they still look on course
to to wind do you really think that
these issues at the next general
election in Britain
okay which of them if they can rise in
in salience will will it will be
significant in their next election
immigration for sure
um it's the second issue for 2019
conservatives and it's about to become a
much bigger issue in British Politics as
we see net migration rise from 504 000
last year to depending who you talk
about in government and I talk to a lot
of people in the Civil Service who tell
me this week
um you know mid-may 2023 uh that we're
looking at somewhere between 700 000 and
a million which is remarkable given that
it was 230 000 when David Cameron took
office in 2010. now why is Labor ahead
in the polls well they're ahead in the
polls because opposition parties don't
win elections governments lose them
there is no Mass public enthusiasm for
kierstama and there was very little
public enthusiasm for labor this isn't
1997 when all we were talking about was
public services and education this isn't
electorate that was incredibly weary
angry frustrated and is basically saying
the country is in such a state let's let
the other guys have a go if you ask them
about these key issues who can solve
the immigration question is one example
the most popular answer is not labor
it's none of them
there's a massive reservoir of
disillusionment over that question if
you ask voters
um who do you think can solve crime
massive amount of disillusionment nobody
thinks left and right have the answers
and because we're in a majoritarian
system there are no Alternatives now if
we're in PR if we had a proportional
representation system uh we'd have other
parties that would be much more visible
but because voters are pushed into one
of the two you know they have to
ultimately ultimately make a choice and
and this is where I still think genuine
I'm happy for people obviously to
disagree with me I think there is so
much space right now for something
different in British politics that
really said to both left and right
you've fundamentally failed over the
last 30 years you failed for economic
reasons you failed for cultural reasons
um you're increasingly failing with
regard to this
transformation of our culture which I
think is the most unbritish thing that
has been happening I mean the point
about woke or political correctness is
not that it's a number one issue in the
country it's that it is increasingly
pervading everything
so I'll give you an example I did a
project recently I said to to
conservative voters what are the top
issues that you care the most about but
which you feel you are not represented
on okay the top three political
correctness has gone too far and as I
say to politicians in Britain don't say
woke say political correctness everybody
knows what that is only about 45 percent
of people know what work is political
correctness has gone too far
immigration is out of control
and we need to do more to protect
Britain's distinctive identity culture
and history those are the three issues
that that conservatives care the most
about and feel that they're not
represented on you might also throw
crime into that mix so that raises an
intriguing question what if we actually
add a conservative
leader of the conservative party what if
we actually had somebody who came out
tomorrow and said you know what
I don't want to have an economy built
around importing cheap migrant labor for
the next 20 years I don't want to have a
country that can't solve the housing
crisis while running net migration at
500 000 and I don't want a country that
is still falling over itself to invest
in London and the graduate class while
ignoring everybody else and I don't want
a country that is increasingly
exposing our children to an experiment
that has no basis in science
that person would be very popular that
person would lose sw1 in London in two
days but out there in the wider country
they would be incredibly popular because
they would be saying what everybody is
basically thinking which is that this
experiment this liberal Revolution isn't
working in Practical or but rather on
the party political side in what do you
think the Tories in government can do on
the issue of immigration what policy now
what what could they do to convince
voters that they they're the ones who
can actually deal with it if it's as you
say this alien one of the Salient issues
or do you think it's it's too late I
don't think the conservatives can fix
the prop can fix the issue can fix the
problem and I do think it's a problem
for me immigration has always been about
the political economy right it's not
about the people it's it's the fact that
we as a country have now become
dependent on a Model that is basically
driven by Cheap workers and consumption
right and then we sit here and say well
why is productivity so low why are
growth rates so low and why are so many
people feeling as though they have no
real control and influence over the
decisions that are affecting their daily
lives
after brexit the conservatives who Boris
Johnson made a very they took a
conscious decision
um to liberalize
non-european migration not many people
realize what they were doing at the time
but they basically said look we're going
to re-pivot reposition and we're going
to open the door to record numbers of
people from outside of Europe Nigerians
zimbabweans etc etc and what we're also
going to do is we're going to say to
everybody that this is a high skill
immigration policy we're attracting The
Best of the Best
and then we're going to reduce the
salary thresholds for worker visas to 21
000 pounds or 25 000 pounds in in most
sectors the average wage in this country
is about 33 000. so you're looking at it
and you're thinking well we're being
told we've got a high school immigration
policy we're being told that the British
people have got control but we've got a
Visa program here with salary thresholds
which are about 10 grand below the
average wage
and also Boris Johnson removed the
requirement for British companies to
advertise jobs in Britain first now that
to me does not seem like it was a
reasonable satisfactory response to the
brexit vote and the worst bit about all
of this is is they then let open the
floodgates on International students and
their relatives why does that matter
well I work in universities so I'll tell
you
the whole point of brexit for many
people was to get off this economy that
is producing too many graduates when
there aren't enough graduate jobs about
a third of graduates aren't working in
graduate jobs because there are too many
graduates we need fewer universities and
we need to get more kids doing trades
you're going to technical colleges
becoming doctors by the way because we
don't allow enough of them to become
doctors or to become medical
professionals and uh what the
government's done is said no actually
we're going to keep this broken model
going by allowing even more
International students into the country
in order to keep broken universities
afloat which therefore removes any
incentive for universities to invest in
you know building relationships with
community colleges and and helping
apprentices and all the rest of it and
so on all the tough decisions that the
conservative should have taken all the
difficult choices they went for the easy
option so they can't solve the migration
question they don't want to solve the
migration question and that's why
they're fixated on small boats and they
might be able to slow down the numbers
if they get the Rwanda policy working
they might be able if they're brave
enough to do some things like reforming
a human rights act or possibly leaving
the European conventional human rights
but I would make a bet with you Winston
that a year from now we'll be looking at
net migration that's somewhere around
close to a million will probably have
had another 70 80 000 people crossing
the channel in the boats and the
politics of immigration which can often
be very divisive and very ugly
which we really should have put to bed
after the brexit referendum
that they will be back with a bang I try
to understand why the Tories have have
allowed this and this immigration to
just Skyrocket like it has is it because
they're trying to deal with the
population growth decline the underlying
Logic for the conservative party I think
is twofold one is
and this is what I said at the
conference which is I think Ruffles and
feathers in the conservative party is
they've consistently put business before
the national community and that's the
reality of the conservative party the
aftermath of brexit they they face a
choice right they could have stood up to
business and so we're not going to keep
just funneling cheap migrant labor to
you to keep your costs down to keep
profits up and to stop you from
investing in British people and
developing British skills and innovating
and automating the rest of it
they didn't they failed they just said
the first real test they fell over and
said no we're gonna okay right sorry
um you know Simon Wilson and next and
big business sorry okay you can't get
Workers we're going to keep workers
coming sorry we'll keep the Taps on
um so that's that was the first part of
the logic and the second is to be frank
most stories are status conscious
stories they don't really like to get
drawn into cultural disputes over you
know immigration and identity it's very
difficult for them they don't want to
get drawn into the work stuff as we saw
in response to the netcon conference
because they think honor this is beneath
us when we don't do this this is
cultural stuff which is why today's
conservatives are actually very
different from an early generation of
conservatives who were basically aware
of the fact that they are custodians of
the nation they're not just here to
serve business they're not just here to
drive the economy that's in massively
important part of what they're doing but
they're also here to defend institutions
to pass on a cultural inheritance and to
look after families and I think at every
turn since brexit the conservatives have
shown that actually they're not really
all that interested in doing those
things they view those things as quite
cranky it's quite Fringe and one of the
fascinating comparisons to make today is
between Britain and Sweden so why is it
the British conservatives lowered the
salary thresholds and basically kept us
dependent on low-skill migration whereas
the Swedish conservatives have just said
we are not going to have low salary
thresholds we're going to keep them at
least at the average wage if not higher
because if people are coming in and we
want them to be high skilled and we want
them to be contributing to the economy
we have not done that we've done the
opposite and here's something that would
you know is obviously going to ruffle
some feathers and is a bit of a
controversial point to make but I'll
make it a lot of the people who are now
coming in under the post-brexit
liberalization are not going to be
contributing anywhere near as much to
the National economy as the people who
were coming in before I know a number of
studies now that have shown that
low-skilled migrants coming from other
parts of the world are going to
contribute less to the British economy
than let's say the French and the
Spanish and the Greeks and the latvians
and so on and this is reflected in our
housing system it's 60 of social housing
in London is going to people who aren't
British and we've got this housing
crisis yet we've got you know depending
on what estimate you use a couple of
hundred thousand homes sitting in
offshore tax Havens for foreign
investors so this is where the politics
of immigration is going it's going to
increasingly be linked to housing it's
going to increasingly be linked to
Public Services which is why I keep
saying to the conservances if you don't
get on top of this
if you don't get on top of this you are
leaving yourselves wide open
to a major challenge a kind of
reconfiguration of the right which is
what the conference this week in
Westminster was about the national
conservatism conference where there are
now serious people you know this isn't a
fringe thing serious cabinet ministers
serious MPS serious donors thinkers who
are just saying you know what this brand
of conservative politics has has run
into a cul-de-sac it doesn't have the
answers to today's problems the I mean
I'd go further it's been a complete and
utter disaster they've had power for 13
years cost of living crisis migrant
crisis as you described uh Douglas
Murray in his speech at the netcon
conference articulated very well how can
you expect young people
to want to play the capitalist game or
or be capitalists if they're unable to
accumulate Capital because of the
housing crisis is of the obvious
implication there this has all happened
under the watch of of the conservative
party over uh I said 50 something like
53 percent of
fat
households now take more work from
welfare than they put in top 10 of the
country pay for over half of income tax
it's a welfare state this has all
happened under the Tories
the only thing I can see that the tours
have achieved in the last 13 years is
brexit there's nothing leveling up has
been leveling down and I I don't it's
it's completely therefore as you said
earlier in in this conversation it's
they're they're losing this well I
speaking to you in The Spectator so I
don't need to tell you you this as you
know the spectators led the debate on
this but if you just look at what's
happened to welfare over the last decade
you know the irony was that David I
remember David Cameron and George
Osborne you know really going after
Labor in terms of how many people they
essentially encouraged to become reliant
on the welfare state losing dignity
meaning and purpose in their lives but
as we're sat here today there's close to
five million people on working age uh
working age people on benefits
um what we've done is we've sort of
agreed not to talk about that and fill
the holes with with migrant labor so
it's it's a very difficult one and it's
also one that is going to become
increasingly visible to everybody over
the next 10 20 years because the other
part of the logic for the conservative
party and they're right to worry about
it but they're wrong to berate National
conservatives for talking about it which
is we have a massive demographic crisis
looming in this country you know we are
25 I think you know is going to be one
of the the last years where essentially
more people are going to be more Brits
are going to be dying than being born
and the fertility rate now is already
down to about 1.5 so you're basically
looking at a welfare state an economy
that over the next 50 years unless you
have large amounts of inward migration
or controversial you encourage British
families to have more children Maybe by
having a pro-family tax policy Maybe by
having pro-family Norms throughout
Society maybe actually having a
conversation about how we might
encourage people to do that
um we're going to have to have lots and
lots and lots of more more immigration
and that already immigration is the
biggest driver of population growth in
this country
so over the next 10 20 years the country
will become visibly very very different
I mean by 20 by 2060 if you look look at
the estimates from Oxford and I just say
this to to to give you a sense of the
pace of change not because I think it's
necessarily problematic but to give you
a sense of the change so by 2060 it's
estimated that the percentage of white
British citizens will go from around
about 80 to about 60 percent and by
which means that in most primary schools
by the 2050s or thereabouts essentially
white British kids will be will be a
minority
and so the pace of Change is Going to Be
enormous so what we've seen over the
last 20 years is really nothing compared
to what we're going to see over the next
20 we're going to add about another 5
million people to the population by 2040
which is like five birminghams so the
population change will be enormous and
our capacity for dealing with that with
infrastructure Health housing
is going to be tested like never before
so we either come up with a generation
of leaders who are realistic about how
much
migration we can deal with given those
challenges or we try and push forward
new people who can at least begin to
address some of those problems and raise
the conversations about those problems I
mean the response to netcon to the
conference was fascinating and that
somebody said the Ft or the new
Statesman or somebody said um oh they're
talking about
demography and birth rates as if this is
like a taboo I mean the problem I have
with this country is we're not a serious
country when we talk about social and
cultural problems much of the world is
talking about the demographic Time Bomb
much of the world is talking about aging
societies much of the world is talking
about how to develop pro-family policies
but in Britain where our national
conversation is dominated by social
liberals and progressives who will
basically use this to try and stain
people as being you know right-wing or
Victor Orban sympathizers or whatever
we're just not a serious country we're
not even capable of having the policy
debates that we need to have in order to
solve these problems that was actually
quite the two speeches at the netcon
that come to mind were Louise Perez and
Ed West who were they were my favorite
speeches yeah they were prepared to talk
about that specific thing and I I really
challenge any anyone who considered
himself different political opinion to
to disagree with the fundamentals of
what they were saying particularly
Louise Perry's argument about supporting
mothers I mean just forget forget about
all like the what it means for the
identity change of the nation just don't
we want to support women don't we want
to support mothers it seems like that
it's it was so refreshing actually to
hear
that that being spoken about like it's
it's how that's been neglected from
British politics is is shameful it's
actually how the family has been
neglected I mean if you look at you know
we have the highest rates of family
breakdown in in the Western World some
of the highest we're on on course to
have some of by the end of this decade
the largest number of single parent
families in Europe we already have a 43
of kids in this country by the time they
turn 18 are no longer living with mum
and dad
um so we have a we have an enormous
family problem and and the reaction by
the way to some of the speeches at
netcon online were saying well what's
the problem with single mothers look I'm
I was raised by a single mother and I
said in my speech you know my parents
divorced when I was five so the idea
that talking about family breakdown is
reactionary is divisive is problematic
the people who say that have absolutely
no idea what they're talking about
because if if you look at the evidence
on family breakdown and if you you want
the evidence go online Google family
inequalities in a field you can get the
report came at the end of last year it
is completely comprehensive and it tells
a very consistent picture kids who come
from broken homes are more likely to do
worse in the education system more
likely to be arrested more likely to
pass through
prisons and the criminal justice system
more likely to be depressed more likely
to have mental health problems off the
charts and a lot of these things and by
the way there is actually a significant
difference between kids who are braced
in a in a cohabiting couple
from kids who are raised and are married
couple there is actually a difference
between those two and I know this is
difficult for people to talk about but
it's true and this is not to take
anything away from single mothers I
would like I'm able to say my single
mother is one of the strongest most
impressive people I've ever met in my
life but I would still rather have been
raised in a two-parent family if you
look at the evidence it's overwhelming I
would have done better I would have been
more stable etc etc so we we need to be
able to have these conversations and we
need to be able to have them in a way
that is reasonable evidence-led and say
okay so what could we do well we could
change the way in which we tax uh
families we could tax them as families
not as individuals we could
um change the way we distribute child
care we could push back against Jeremy
Hunt who clearly views Mothers and
Fathers as economic units who need to
leave the home as quickly as possible
and get back to work you know when all
the evidence shows that actually
children should really be with their
mothers for as long as possible during
the first three years if not longer and
we need to be able to have these
arguments and take these arguments to
the mainstream parties and I just don't
see any of the people who are doing that
with the exception of you know Miriam
case Danny Krueger and some of the
people at the conference who are
actually willing to say we need to be
able to talk about the politics of
family families are not just kind of
fluid entities that are defined by
anything and everything we know what a
good stable productive successful family
structure looks like and if you even
disagree with all of that and you're a
ruthless pragmatist then just perhaps
Ponder the fact that having strong
families is the greatest return on
investment that any society can make I
mean think of the financial savings and
the impact on GDP by having strong
cohesive family units in society I mean
if you want the rational case for you
know the economic instrumental case for
families is there right but if you want
the moral case as in actually this is
why we should really be talking about it
that's there too so why don't we why
don't we actually have a serious
discussion about it absolutely before we
go into the the nakcon conference we've
already gone into it a little bit
some listeners will find both the words
National nationalists and conservative
as kind of they'll have allergic
reactions to the words immediately so
before we go into what is the National
Health Service
[Music]
um
can you give your I mean like
nationalism is conflated with jingoism
the Holocaust uh the sins of of the 20th
century a lot of them what can you make
a the case for nationalism detached from
those things or or is it under are they
right to say that uh it's it's attached
to those sort of uh since yeah one of my
favorite speeches I mean all of them
obviously are online uh on YouTube uh
one of my favorite speeches was by
Timothy Stanley the telegraph uh uh
columnist writer and uh he was asked
this question by a prominent journalist
Ian Dale who said oh well the problem
with this movement is it's called itself
National conservatism and Tim Tim said
well what's the problem with that he
said well national socialism at which
points him so well maybe we should have
a word with the National Trust and the
National Health Service or the nspcc I
mean it's it's a bizarre State of
Affairs where we're not even able to
talk about the nation state and that's
kind of where we've we've got into and
that is Nation statism that's that in
itself reflects the power of
new the new Elite social liberals and
radical progressives in the institutions
that certain things are considered taboo
I don't know of many countries outside
of Western Europe that would come close
to thinking like that yeah yeah we do
National conservatism in my mind is a is
a very distinctive political movement
which wants to put the interests of the
national Community First which wants to
prioritize communities over individuals
and which wants to ensure that families
um and
um communities and neighborhoods are
promoted and protected from Global uh
Global globalization and Global
interests and that's why National
conservatives are supportive of very
supportive of lowering
immigration they're instinctively
skeptical of large-scale global
corporations and business
they want to celebrate the
distinctiveness of national identity
they don't just want britishness or
englishness to be reshaped as a
celebration of international diversity
and multiculturalism
they're very welcoming of people who are
genuinely in need of help but they're
very suspicious us and skeptical of
people who are seen to abuse the system
uh and I think it's fair to say that the
view of most national conservatives is
if you are not embracing British values
and respecting British institutions then
you should consider
um you know not living in Britain I mean
that I think is a fair response and
that's why they've been willing to talk
about things that that many other people
haven't been willing to talk about
they've talked about the sexual
exploitation of children through the
grooming Scandal they've talked about
what's happening in schools where
children are being taught there are 72
genders
um they're willing to talk about the
demographic
Time Bomb but they're also willing to
talk about industrial strategy how to
build an economy that isn't dependent on
London how to drive growth in a serious
way that isn't just based around
consumption and flooding the market with
workers from overseas they're willing to
say you know actually I don't think we
should just import doctors and nurses I
think we should expand the number of
medical places for British kids so that
they can actually become doctors and
nurses and go into their Health Care
system and they're willing to say Tony
Blair was wrong we shouldn't just have a
nation full of University degree holders
we should have you know a true One
Nation you know we should have uh
apprentices and technical colleges and
vocational education producing
alternative routes into leading a
successful life and one of the most
interesting ideas I heard at netcon was
well you know if you want to discuss
reforming the House of Lords here's an
idea why don't we have a a people's
chamber that reflects the different
um the different uh trades and the
different skills and the different
communities that we have in this country
there's one way of reforming the House
of Lords in an interesting way that
would send a message that we value work
we we see dignity in work we see meaning
in work
um and I think there are just many
things that we we could do in this
country that that send a very loud
signal that the social and economic
settlement has changed you know and and
the I'm not in the book obviously I'm
quite critical of Margaret Thatcher but
I never say you know many of the things
Margaret Thatcher did were necessary at
the time but they were it was a set of
answers to a different set of questions
and and I what worries me about the
conservatives today is that they still
think they're living in 1988 and they're
still providing answers but but to the
the wrong answers to to an old set of
questions and they haven't quite got the
right answers
to the new questions well on that you
you criticized in your speech in that
con the ultra free Traders I think was
your term although although you didn't
expand on that and I I would be curious
what you meant by Ultra free Traders
yeah so when you go to the 19 go back to
the 1990s and the early 2000s the whole
debate about globalization led by
Tony Blair Larry Summers among others
lots of folks in the European Union was
that globalization the deregulation of
economies liberalizing Finance
um increasing free trade global trade
would lift all boats in society it was a
good thing symbolized by Blair's speech
in 2005 where he famously said if you
don't support globalization if you're
not on board you basically don't
understand the world right it
essentially said you know you're you're
an idiot if you don't get this
what we now know through the work of
David Auto David Dawn among others in
economics is that the the the
deregulation and liberalization of
finance and the opening up of national
economies to to Global free trade
um had disproportionately negative
effects on working-class voters in
Western economies
um especially non-graduate workers in
industrial communities that were hit
hard by the economic shocks of growing
trade with China and in Britain in part
trade with places other places in Europe
and that did two things one is it's
significantly lowered uh wages
um and uh and and the economic interests
of what of those workers but crucially
secondly you know a number of a number
of papers now that show it also
undermined family stability and
undermined the social Fabrics or the
community fabric that where you had
areas that were suddenly exposed to
these big shocks or that suddenly had a
really big influx of of cheap migrant
workers from central eastern Europe as
part of this this project it wasn't just
that domestic workers lost money it was
that there were higher rates of family
breakdown higher rates of so-called
drugs of Despair people turning to
cocaine heroin alcohol so-called slow
motion suicides and communities became
weaker in many of those areas and what
always irritates me about British Tories
and conservatives and free Traders by
that I mean economic liberals who who
believe passionately that actually we we
need to do more of that we need to
deregulate the stress MOG who made a
speech yeah partly respawned you know
but we need to basically deregulate you
know take caps off Bankers bonuses
prioritize a city what makes me nervous
about that
is I've never yet heard any of them tell
me their view about that evidence which
shows that it not only undermines the
domestic it not only undermines domestic
workers but damages the fabric of
families and communities so I think
there has to be an alternative model
that is that is much more focused at
doing what that first not first wave of
globalization but what that 90s wave of
globalization 2000s wave didn't do and
it didn't think seriously about how to
compensate or prepare The Losers of
globalization for what was coming
everybody just said get on with it it
will be fine boats will be lifted and we
now know that it wasn't fine and that's
why support for brexit was strongest in
those communities so I support for
farage was strongest in those
communities it's why many of those
voters in the red wall and elsewhere
said you know what actually I can sense
I think I think Boris Johnson is talking
talking about a different brand of
politics from Margaret Thatcher it
sounds like this leveling up thing this
kind of brexit thing this kind of
lowering immigration thing to me it
sounds like that's quite different yeah
from Thatcher and everything now of
course we now know it wasn't really all
that different at all
um but many of those voters I think had
been shaped by that experience
um and that's what I mean that I think
the free Traders don't really reflect
enough on the the problems and the
failures of of that project in the 80s
90s and 2000s you consider yourself more
of a protectionist not necessarily A
protectionist but I think certainly
somebody that's instinctively skeptical
of globalization I am very skeptical of
globalization because I think I've seen
too many cases where
large corporates have basically sold
local people down the river you know
corporates are fundamentally
self-interested entities which I you
know it sometimes that is incredibly
helpful and it works and it drives
economies but they are not very good and
really acknowledging and and and
responding to the importance of
community and and tradition and cohesion
and you know you could see that in large
parts of the red wall under you know new
labor
um and uh where you would see the the
story I remember most vividly was um the
Sports Direct Factory that was set up on
the site of an old of an old mine
and the old mine used to keep that
Community going and you know not to
romanticize it but it also gave people a
powerful sense of belonging and the when
the Sports Direct Factory opened I think
there were 13 000 jobs somewhere around
that and um the the owner
um uh of the company bust in essentially
cheap migrant workers who work for less
and who took the bulk of those jobs and
that to me is not a responsible
productive capitalism that's a predatory
capitalism and and that's that's the
stuff that makes me instinctively
nervous and anxious about the
conservative parties Embrace of some of
that and it was also underlined by Liz
truss I think her I thought I found it
very revealing that one of her first
political moves was to lift the cap on
Bankers bonuses and then to start
negotiating a trade deal with India that
would have essentially had pretty
relaxed free movement and I just don't
understand at the time I didn't really
understand how prioritizing
the city and more migration was a
suitable response to the politics of
brexit I think it would have made much
more sense to say we've promised people
a serious leveling up strategy yeah
we've promised people uh one nation
economy all of our mid-level cities in
Britain routinely underperform their
counterparts across much of Europe
I mean outside of London I mean all of
our mid-level cities really are nowhere
near as dynamic as and as Innovative as
they should be and I just never really
saw the conservatives Embrace that and
come up with some interesting ideas for
dealing with that what we did see was
Southeastern conservative MPS
complaining that too much money and
investment or even talking about areas
north of the M25 was somehow
unconservative or problematic and that
to me reflected the roots of the
conservative party but also just
reflected the kind of General
disinterest that you often find in
London with areas
that are outside of the country so I am
instinctively skeptical of of the
conservatives on the economy which by
the way makes me an average voter
because if you look at an average time
it's quite similar to Blue labor look
what you've just well yeah but if you
look at the average rotor too they are a
little bit more to the economic left and
a little bit what quite a way to the
cultural right than most of the people
who sit in the House of Commons and that
basically is the tension running through
all of this you know so it's almost as
though
I mean you know he won't but if
kierstama came out tomorrow and said you
know look actually I think we should
probably nationalize water companies I
think we should probably
um you know lower corporation tax or
give companies big tax incentives to
invest in non-land areas of the economy
and we should have an immigration cap
and increase the salary thresholds
he would alienate some radical
progressives but boy would it be popular
everywhere everywhere else you know I
mean whether he's got the Charisma to
pull that off whether I mean he
certainly doesn't have the courage but I
think it would be an interesting
experiment and that's where the action
is I mean if you look at you look at
France you look at Italy you look at
Sweden you look at America you know look
at what Biden's done on a lot of issues
you know big infrastructure and
Industrial policy we just seem to be way
behind the curve on a lot of this
because I it just feels to me over the
last three four years we've just become
a very anti-intellectual country we've
become quite inward looking we haven't
really engaged fully with the way in
which political movements elsewhere are
evolving
um and I think that's why the British
Tories look very weak and vulnerable so
uh back to the the netcon conference
some of the pushback that's that's been
online seems to have tied in a little
bit with your book The the sort of
Cosmopolitan uh disdain for uh ideas
that will be popular amongst working
normal people uh particularly thinking
of Emily matless describing sort of
lumping everyone together as conspiracy
theorists anti-vaxxers
um Auntie she's used the term
anti-migrant rather and then
anti-immigration or anti-immigrant
rather than anti-immigration which is an
interesting yeah distinction that she's
made there but uh all in all not
engaging yeah properly with the the
discussions that are being had
um what do you think why do you think
this is so has been so controversial
well I think partly
um it reflects the power of the new
Elite in the National conversation uh I
think Emily maitless John sopel and
Lewis Goodall are you know real examples
great examples of who I call the new
Elite I think there is a there is a
um
there are a group of journalists and
commentators who essentially view
anything outside of the liberal
consensus which is shared by about 20 of
the country if you look at the British
social attitude survey about 20 of Brits
are are sort of strongly and
consistently liberal on a whole Suite of
issues if you step outside of that by
talking about things like lowering
immigration
seeing the best in Britain
objecting to the portrayal of our
society is as racist as talking about
the importance of family
talking about the importance of clamping
down on crime
saying we should talk about why so many
young children were sexually exploited
by grooming gangs and we do want to ask
why so many journalists
refuse to go near it they just can't
handle that it's outside of this very
narrow Overton window that they've
constructed and that's why by the way
you see the media landscape fragmenting
rapidly since the brexit referendum BBC
Radio 4 today has lost 1.7 million
weekly listeners wow why do we have
um
out out
outputs like this the new podcasts why
do we have
GB News Talk TV why do we have unheard
why do we have
um you know spiked why do we have this
flourishing ecosystem
um
full of people who I think all sense
that the Legacy institutions dominated
typically by Elite graduates who come
from professional managerial families
who tend to share the same sets of
radically progressive socially liberal
values and you tend to basically deride
everybody else's racist bigots and
idiots who don't understand the
complexity of the modern world
I think those people are now saying look
we need to have a different kind of
national conversation in this country
and I I personally find it quite
refreshing that the moment you know very
senior journalists like Emily mate
listen
John cipel leave the BBC and they really
tell us what they think it's like oh
yeah okay I I kind of thought that that
was the case all along and now I know
now I know and um and this is reflected
in the evidence that I talk about in the
book I mean 90 of our journalists now
belong to the graduate class half of
them went to one of two universities
local media's collapsed Regional media
has collapsed they go straight from the
universities into the media Newsroom
where they're basically surrounded by
people who look like them come from the
same backgrounds
um and I sit in focus groups with voters
all the time and so many people sit at
home watching the adverts on TV watching
the media debates watching the
discussions and just asking themselves
where is this country I mean seriously
if you live in Boston and skegness or if
you live in Northampton or you live in
clacton or you live in
um South Wales and you watch the adverts
on British TV
and you actually look at the the way in
which this country is portrayed along
you know very socially liberal radically
Progressive lines
um I think a lot of people are just
wondering what's happened to the
creative class what's happened to the
cultural institutions and I don't think
this is a this isn't a conspiracy I mean
it's it's simply that the institutions
are dominated by the graduates graduates
have moved left on cultural questions
and they've taken the institutions with
them this is what in the US they call
the Great Awakening that as white
graduate liberals have basically
radicalized over the last 10 years in
response to Donald Trump in response to
brexit in response to all of these
things that have shocked their system
and I understand that I mean I I think
many levers felt the same way about
Blair or felt the same way about Cameron
um but as they've been shocked by these
things they've moved leftwards
culturally and and so now we're at a
point where they're not even capable
of actually having a conversation about
these issues I don't think I've ever
seen anybody on Aleister Campbell's show
James O'Brien show
the Emily Maitland show that directly
and openly challenges their worldview
now why do I say that because if you
look at the evidence on
um Elite graduates or uh social liberals
they are consistently the most likely to
unfriend block
um and insult people who hold different
beliefs to their own they're the most
likely to say they would feel
uncomfortable if one of their kids
married somebody who voted for brexit or
somebody who who held gender critical
views so the idea that we have a kind of
uh liberal enlightened tolerant open
um Elite Class I'm afraid I don't see it
I just don't see it I see a group that
is basically trying to shut down or
stigmatize people who want to challenge
the consensus and and that to me is not
liberal at all and I think voters have
picked up on that that's why 60 percent
now say I can't say what I really want
to say in this country because I feel as
though political correctness has become
too too stifling do you think the
British sorry the national conservative
movement
is one of the movements or the movement
to come and fill the void that they're
leaving politically do you think it's
one of the movements that could I think
on both the right and the left you're
seeing you're seeing the rise of people
who are trying to have a different
conversation right and I talked to
everybody left right whatever and I
think you can see on the left
they're all you know podcasts and
YouTube channels and so on that are
trying to have a different conversation
about the country and I think on the
right you can see that two I think the
reaction to the National conservative
conference has been revealing and that
it got so much reaction I think that
shows that people grasp that actually
there is an argument there that is going
to cut through and resonate with much of
the rest of the country and I think the
fact that much of that coverage was
instinctively hostile was openly hostile
um shows again
um how people are trying to
control the national conversation in a
way that that upholds the existing
consensus I mean Michael Lind wrote a
wonderful book recently called the new
class War uh in which he says that um
you know one of the problems with the
managerial professional overclass today
is that they will basically denigrate
everybody who disagrees with them as you
know racist of transphobe Lunatic Fringe
cranky partly to ensure and to try and
prevent any serious opposition to the
project from from emerging and there are
look I mean there are races in our
society and there are transphobes but
most of the people who are asking
themselves why this economy isn't
working and why the society isn't
working I don't think are particularly
bad people
um but I think they've tweaked that
actually are political conversationism
reflecting their values and voice
but are you optimistic or pessimistic
about the future of this country I'm
very uh I'm I'm very pessimistic
um because I um
I'm increasingly uh of the view that
left and right don't represent
much of the country anymore I think the
the big winner at the next election will
be apathy I think lots of people would
just not participate and
um I think the pace of change that is
going to be sweeping through Britain
over the next 20 30 years
and the the lack of long-term planning
for that
and that the lack of long-term
um policy work that is needed to get
Britain ready for that and to address
the challenges that we've got
um leaves me very pessimistic about
where we're going to be in in the years
ahead because even my students you know
my Zuma students from gen Z were born in
2004 my first years
um they're very gloomy about the
direction of the country because they
say how can we get a house how can we
get into this labor market uh how can we
you know Thrive and prosper
um you know we're not we're not only
competing with with
previous generations who had things much
easier but were also now competing with
you know Rising numbers of of people
from overseas
um you know who often have more more
support than they do so I think we're
going to uh we're going to have some
real challenges over the next 20 30 40
years so I'm I'm pessimistic I'm not at
the point where I've given up but I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm gloomy and that's why I
think we need to work at reforming and
reshaping the institutions to ensure
that they get a wider pool of talent in
them and they give more of a voice to
people who come from different parts of
our country and voice is really really
important that's partly what brexit was
about it's partly what 2019 was about
and it's why so many people are turning
up at these strange but very busy
conferences in Westminster on a Monday
and a Tuesday you know in the middle of
May that I think that people are sensing
that actually we're going to need
something else to meet those challenges
well on this that's a slightly more
positive note than it is the pessimism
but I always even hope that your
pessimism might encourage people
convinced by your arguments to actually
they should be engaging and being part
of the change thank you Matt thank you
for your time thanks for having me
[Music]
foreign